at the white house the job of interpreting
every word falls to a groundbreaking team
of american sign language interpreters
ed o'keefe takes us inside their work
good afternoon at the white house the president
first lady and the press secretary are usually the
most familiar faces but for thousands of americans
that box in the right hand corner of the white
house live stream is where their eyes usually
focus elsie snecker is the first official white
house american sign language interpreter this is
a dream job of that combination of the political
information and the interpreting it fits me very
very well every day whenever the president speaks
my fellow americans whenever gensake holds a press
briefing i know there are a few topics to discuss
or when experts like dr anthony foucher share
new information from the white house the safety
of these vaccines have been clearly established
elsie is on screen too i have to recognize and
thank really the deaf community and the grassroots
deaf people who pushed so hard to make sure that
this access was available about half a million use
american sign language which is not the english
version of sign language but its own language
entirely with its own grammar and sentence
structure during the pandemic advocates sued to
get live asl interpretation during covet briefings
we will have an asl and american sign language
interpreter for the biden administration went a
step further hiring elsie who's deaf as a member
of the staff we spoke to her with the assistance
of miaco villanueva who signed my questions to her
and spoke her answers back absolutely i am blessed
to be here and elsie is just one half of a team
this is really the ultimate of team relationships
lindsey snyder who can hear is also an asl
interpreter i am interpreting from english to
asl and i am essentially feeding elsie who then
takes that message and interprets it what i call
it real time editing elsie and lindsey spent
hours each day preparing by reading up on the
news and topics on the white house schedule when
an event starts thank you thank you very very
much lindsay listens then interprets for elsie
we're seeing the beginnings of an american
manufacturing comeback who signs in front of
the camera is the united states is in a position
to out-compete the world once again onto your
screen there's no limit to what we can achieve
none they could just hire someone like lindsay
to do this work but in essence they've gone the
extra step of hiring somebody who is completely
deaf deaf people who are asl users can watch and
identify that it's a deaf person signing on the
screen most hearing interpreters they learned asl
so they have an accent in asl where a deaf person
who grew up using asl doesn't have that same kind
of accent we also as deaf interpreters can gauge
what a deaf audience would potentially need that
some kind of terminology is clearer than others
some things need a little bit more expansion and
explanation natural performers with a great sense
of timing they say the best part of their day
is the daily press briefing one of my favorite
parts and it's actually related to you are you
ready okay often someone will ask a question and
then on infrastructure and she answers it back
on infrastructure and then somebody else asked
a question and i'm like in the back of my mind
didn't they already ask that and then the third
person asked and i'm like she answered it already
so i'm having this argument with myself in the
back of my head while i'm working and trying
to keep my cool on the screen is there something
those of us in the room should be doing to help it
along make friends with your consonants i love i
love a good articulator the one year anniversary
of the american rescue plan i also believe
that no one speaks or reads faster than jensaki
believe it or not elsie and lindsey had never
met saki in person it's so nice to meet you but
we helped arrange a meeting yeah rats briefings
are my favorite we tell everyone i heard maybe
i talk a little fast okay i'll work on that too
this is the ultimate kind of team we have our own
skill set that manages to come together to put out
the most effective message to bring in a community
that's been marginalized for so long i'm not here
for myself to be in this position i'm here for
the deaf community to have access to this message
for cbs mornings i'm ed o'keefe at the white house
ed o'keefe that was so interesting i
never thought about a difference tony
a hearing interpreter and an interpreter who's
deaf that they would translate differently such
a charming interesting piece uh yeah
no the idea that if you are born deaf
you have a different way of signing than a
person who is learning it as a hearing uh
adult that's very interesting like there's an
accent to the movements yeah i'll be curious
to see if jin saki slows down they said she
talks too fast well you've got to be yourself